So in our scene, I talked about the directional light,
and then what you can do to maybe edit it on the fly
and some of the properties and settings that you can use
and that are at your disposal.
What we're gonna do now is look at a few other lights.
The next one we'll look at is the spotlight.
Now the spotlight is great and works very much
like your ones that you may be familiar with
in your DCCs.
It has our intensity control,
but we also have our intensity units.
We can choose what we want.
The default is candlest,
but you can choose whatever is convenient for you.
You'll see that we can control the color
as well as the attenuation radius.
Now the attenuation radius is great
because it allows us to control
how far the influence for this light is going to be
for our environment and the objects nearby.
So the inner cone angle allows us also to control that,
and you'll see it expand and contract
as I move it around, allowing us to control this
if we want it to look like a particular type of spotlight
with a different type of drop-off and fall-off
from the inside to the out, that's up to you.
But you'll also notice we also have our source radius.
Now the source radius, again,
can control how that reflective object is being handled
and being affected by that spotlight.
Let's go and duplicate the spotlight for a second.
We'll do this a little bit more with a point light
so it makes it a little more obvious,
but you can kind of get an idea how this works.
I'm gonna keep my finger on the Alt key
and move this around,
and let's see if we can put this on a reflective object
so you can kind of get a better idea how this works.
So if I move this a bit closer,
we can see the hotspots coming off the spotlight,
and we'll move it up so you can see it
a little bit better here
at the very top of our lighting,
and you'll see the hotspot right here
where my cursor's pulsing.
Now you'll notice, again,
we have the inner cone angle and the outer cone angle
where we can adjust the size of this light
and how the fall-off is controlled
from the outside and the inside.
But you'll also notice, then,
our source radius here that we can control.
So I can control my source radius,
and you're gonna see that reflective surface object
get a bit bigger.
It's almost like we're adjusting the size of this light.
Kind of not, but at the same time,
it's almost like you can think of it as overexposure,
making this have a stronger hotspot in a way,
but locally to the light, it's actually kind of cool.
But you'll also notice we have a soft source radius,
and you can see this a little bit better
with the spotlight, but you can see as I do this,
it is softening up.
So that reflective hotspot that's happening isn't so sharp.
And again, that's kind of the same effect you had here.
We didn't see it quite as well
with our directional light,
but it's definitely very visible
when it comes to the spotlight
and also the point light.
Awesome.
So we kind of have some of the same settings
we had before.
We'll have the use temperature,
effects of the world, cast shadows,
indirect lighting intensity,
and also volumetric scatter intensity
when it comes to the fog.
But this spotlight is great and works very much
like your other DCC spotlights.
It's pretty straightforward,
but we also have an IES profile that we can load in here.
And those are some of the things
we'll talk about in other classes.
Let's go ahead and take a moment
and take a look at our skylight.
So the skylight in our scene,
and I'm going to select it for a moment.
You'll see, and let me pull him up
and just pull him over
so you're a little bit more familiar with the icon.
It looks like,
let's move away from the other objects here.
He looks like kind of a dome
with two, like three little hash kind of tick marks here
coming down from it.
And this is our skylight in Unreal.
And the skylight allows us to quickly get some GI.
Now, when you're working with Lumen by default,
this should be on,
but you want to turn on real time,
effects real time here.
And you're able to also load
whatever cube map that you want.
Now, what we're using is right now,
it is using our scene information
and the GI bouncing around.
And the only reason it's stuttering a little bit
when I move my camera,
I don't think it's your playback here.
It's just, I'm a really bad driver.
The only reason that this is set up here
is by default, it's plucking from your scene
and bouncing around
and getting that information from the GI
and applying it to this.
Like it's almost making its own internal HDRI map
and applying it to your scene.
You can think of it that way.
But if you wanted to,
you can make it so that you're turning off
the real time calculation for that.
And then you can go in here and say,
SLS, our little specified cube map,
we can put in here
so that we're using our skylight cube map,
specified cube map.
We can choose whatever we want.
And you'll see when I turn it off,
it now isn't grabbing it from our information,
from our sky or light bouncing around.
So it's not quite as cool looking.
It doesn't seem to,
it kind of separates itself from the rest of the scene.
But if I wanted to,
I can now pluck one that we already have,
or one that I can grab from such places as HDR Haven
and load it into our scene.
And it will load.
Now, this is really up to you how you want to do this.
I prefer using real time capture,
but there will be times
when I will need a specific GI coming in
through this skylight
and I'll want to pluck that in there.
So every once in a while,
I'll be like, hmm, this isn't working for me.
I need to push these values.
And that's really helpful to have that.
So you have source cube map angle too you can control.
We don't have a cube map loaded in here,
but if we did,
we're able to go in here and control that.
And I can do this briefly so you can get an idea.
We can say, hey, turn off the real time there.
And then you can push this through
and you can see the values change a little bit
on our materials here.
And a bit of the light.
Now, remember this isn't like a directional light.
So when you mess with some of these values,
that's gonna more of make it brighter or darker.
It's a little more linear.
There's an absolute control
where the light's coming from per se.
That's more where you would pair
your directional light with it,
with this tool to get it to work the way that you want.
Let's put this back to real time calculation.
So we have cube map resolution.
You can include that too,
as well as sky distance threshold,
how far out that's going to influence your world.
And you can simply do that by changing your views here.
And then if you wanted to in Unreal units,
middle mouse drag and calculate your distance
of where your objects are
versus where you want your skylight to calculate them.
And that can be pretty helpful for you as you need.
So you can say, does it affect the world?
Does it cast shadows, your indirect light intensity,
as well as how this is gonna relate to your fog.
Awesome.
So let's go and move on to a few more lights.
And in the next video,
we're gonna be talking about our point light,
our rec light.
And we're gonna mention a bit briefly
about the HDR backdrop and the sun and sky.
Thanks again.